it's not turn green yep okay hello
welcome to today's live webcast on a
good death
are you that RR euthanasia methods for
lab animals actually humane my name is
dr. Singh Wiccans and I worked the UK
charity the University Federation for
animal welfare and I'll be your
moderator for today's event the
education web seminar is presented by
lab roots and for more information about
this organization visit lab roots calm
few important ounce Montaine firstly
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions about the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we'll try
and answer as many of your questions as
we can and if you wish to enlarge the
slide window click on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window now if you're having any
technical problems either viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button on the top right
of your presentation window or to submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left okay I would now like
to introduce you to today's speaker
my colleague dr. Hugh College he is the
senior scientific program manager at the
university's Federation for animal
welfare and the humane slaughter
Association until recently Hugh was a
researcher at Newcastle University in
the UK and is a current member of the UK
government's advisory body animals in
science committee q Steve thanks and
I'd like to say hello to everyone who's
virtually listening thanks to Japan and
the rest of the organizers for inviting
me to give this talk as Steve said I'm
going to be talking about whether
euthanasia methods for lab animals are
actually humane in other words do we
give these millions of animals that we
use in science every year a good death
because the word euthanasia actually
mean
a good death and that's typically taken
to mean a death which occurs without
pain suffering or distress so do we know
if they actually have a good death and
if not can we work out how to give them
a better death and at the start of these
talks I usually resort to a bit of
semantics because you'll notice through
most of this talk that I'm going to use
the word killing rather than euthanasia
and that is because both youth noisy
means a good death which is means a
humane death and I'm not certain that
the death of every lab animal is humane
and also also because it's sometimes
taken to mean a death which is brought
about to end suffering in when we think
about companion animals being put sleep
or injured animals and lots of lab
animals are killed for reasons other
than to end their suffering because
they're just controlled subjects at the
end of a study animals that have reached
the end of a study over stock at the
breeders and therefore I think it's more
appropriate to use the term killing but
I do understand that lots of people
prefer or a happier with the term
euthanasia so the broad aims of what I
want to do today are to consider the
welfare impact of the way lab animals
are killed
taking rodents as my example most
because we know the most about them I
think and because they're some of the
most common animals in labs and really
just a question whether we understand
the harms of killing them in terms of
whether they suffer when they're killed
and whether those are adequately
represented in harm benefit analysis and
if not suggest what what we might do to
improve things so there are lots of ways
to kill animals and I'm sure you've
heard of lots of these methods cervical
dislocation decapitation all sorts of
physical ways of killing animals and
chemical ways drug overdoses poisons and
so on how do we choose from this great
plethora of methods which ones we should
use for lab animals and libraries
specifically and I think obviously as an
animal welfare is that the primary
concern should be the welfare constraint
in other words choosing the most humane
method the method which causes minimal
pain a little distress and if distress
or pain is unavoidable we may want to
think about using the quickest method
just to limit the duration of any of
these welfare impacts and as a secondary
concern perhaps we should also consider
other animals that are in the presence
of animals being killed because although
the data is not unequivocal there are
suggestions that animals shouldn't
witness other animals being killed
because it may distress them we
shouldn't forget of course that we are
using these animals for scientific
purposes and so there are scientific
constraints quite often on the way we
kill and - if you want samples of the
animals brain to do anatomical or
histological examination you probably
don't want to kill the animal by a
physical method that causes trauma to
the brain on the other hand if you want
to sample certain tissue or blood you
may not want it contaminated with drugs
or other chemicals and there are
situations where you may need to arrest
a physiological process at the time of
death which may necessitate a method
that causes a very rapid death and
perhaps least palatable there are
practical constraints in the real world
cost is an issue some of the equipment
or drugs that are used are expensive
there are also constraints based around
a number of animals it's not uncommon to
need to kill tens or hundreds of animals
in a day you can't really ask one person
to do that one by one using a physical
method so methods where you can kill
more animals or where there's some form
of automation may be preferred
availability of equipment and safety are
also concerned some of the things that
are used to kill these animals are not
particularly safe and if you don't have
the appropriate precautions in your
institution you probably can't use them
and finally something that's often
overlooked is the effect of killing
these animals on the people who do it
and people often find certain methods
more unpleasant than others we shouldn't
be asking people to constantly carry out
methods that they
find unpleasant that clearly shouldn't
dictate which method we use if it
happens that an unpleasant-looking
method is actually more humane but it's
definitely something we need to think
about so having talked about all those
constraints really what I'm concerned
with is welfare so my question is really
how can we tell if the common methods we
use for killing these animals are humane
and as someone who's tried to work on
this I'm going to claim like all
scientist II that the thing they work on
is uniquely difficult but actually I
think this is quite a different question
animal welfare because several of the
roots you have to ask questions of
animals in other welfare questions and
not available to you we can't ask an
animal that's just been killed what
happened to it but you can indirectly
infer what happened to an animal had
something painful occur
similarly we can't use anthropomorphism
because very few human beings know what
it's like to be killed by all of those
gruesome methods that I told you about
but in other situations we can assume
that if a procedure is painful to humans
such as a laparotomy or breaking your
leg that it's probably going to hurt a
rat as well and finally lots of the
things that used to kill these animals
in terms of drugs are agents that
interfere with their behavior in a way
that may preclude them from expressing
signs of poor welfare a sedative drugs
and so on so there are a number of
problems but despite that I'm going to
argue that there's been some really good
progress made lately which does tell us
quite a lot about the welfare impacts of
some of the common methods used to kill
these animals and what I'm going to do
is go through some of the commonly used
methods and just just discuss some of
the welfare issues concerning those
methods and I'm going to start with the
physical techniques which are really
cervical dislocation concussion and
decapitation which I've put in brackets
because at least in Europe there's a
assumption that the capitation should
really only be used when there's a very
strong scientific justification but
nonetheless it is used so it's worth
considering and in the case of cervical
dislocation breaking the neck and
decapitation there are a couple of
welfare concerns that really come up the
first is that although it's sometimes
assumed that these methods effectively
kill animals instantaneously there's
some evidence to the contrary and
there's a bit of data here in this graph
on the left with a red trace which is an
electroencephalogram the brain activity
in a rat which was decapitated at time
zero on that graph where there's a big
vertical spike in the data and what
you'll see is that there's ongoing
activity after that event now this
animal was anesthetized I should say
sorry it's not suffering but what
kangaroo and colleagues infer from this
is that there's a possibility that this
animal would not have lost consciousness
instantaneously
had it been a typical animal undergoing
this procedure so there's a concern that
these animals might have a few seconds
where they have the potential to suffer
and it's even suggested that there are
signatures in that brain activity that
might correspond to nociception and
therefore potentially to pain some
Carter and colleagues have done similar
studies looking at cervical dislocation
and and similarly it doesn't appear to
instantly abolish activity in these
animals brains so that's something of a
concern about these methods alongside
that there's a sort of procedural issue
with cervical dislocation which is that
some studies find that the there is a
significant failure rate when people
attempts of ichael dislocation in small
rodents again this was done in a nice
tight animal so no animals suffered when
this data was obtained but this data
from Larry carbone's lab looking at
people attempting to do cervical
dislocation in any sized animals
suggested
a quite high failure rate and by failure
we mean that the animal kept breathing
probably either because there was no
dislocation of vertebrae or vertebrae in
the thoracic rather than cervical region
were dislocated so there's a sort of
procedural problem there which may be
surmountable by better training but it's
definitely a concern and finally we have
concussion which has sort of dropped off
the radar a bit it's it's not talked
about very much for lab rodents but it
might be the best physical option
because what this involves is hitting
the skull of the animal are more
typically picking out a maluf and
hitting it on a hard object and it
should in theory render the animal
instantly unconscious not necessarily
dead but unconscious effectively
stunning it and therefore it could be
one of the more humane approaches done
right and of course this is a method
that we're really quite comfortable with
when we're talking about soaring live
stuff where we're captive bolts tunning
of large ruminants and so on is is
commonly accepted as a method to stun
them before they're killed so there's
very little experimental data about
rodents but I think it's a method that
people should bear in mind especially
when dealing with small numbers of
animals so we come on now to some of the
chemical methods and to an overdose of
anaesthetic which is another commonly
used way to kill lots of species
pentobarbital is the most commonly used
agent both in labs and it's also what
veterinarians would use to put to sleep
you're on cattle dog quite likely if you
take it to the end of its life the
difference with rodents is that
typically this drug has to be given by
the intraperitoneal route
whereas in larger animals that can be
given intravenously and that actually
raises a few welfare issues of its own
first of all the drug itself well the
solution is quite alkaline there is
potential for pain on injection which is
manifested both as signs of abdominal
rise and
as activation if no septic pathways and
IP injection also means there's a much
longer transition into unconsciousness
than by the IV route and we're not quite
sure how these animals feel during that
long transition to unconsciousness I
should point out that this Spence and
paper that I've referenced and if you if
you can't see the reference please do
email for these references at the end
this Espenson paper does also suggest a
possible solution to ameliorate the pain
on injection by adding lidocaine to the
solution so there is potential to
ameliorate that okay so I'm gonna move
on now for a large bulk of this talk to
looking at exposure to inhaled
substances gases or volatile agents for
killing these animals and really the
ones that I'm going to consider of the
larger group are the most common ones
which are carbon dioxide inert gases
like argon and nitrogen which simply
kill these animals by displacing the air
from the chamber that they're in and
they're fixated and volatile anesthetics
drugs like isoflurane and sevoflurane
which are commonly used for surgery and
don't these drugs don't necessarily kill
the animals they're quite safe that's
why we like them as anesthetics and
certainly if you deliver them from a
vaporizer it's it's going to take you a
long time to kill a box full of mice
with isoflurane but they can be used to
render animals safely unconscious and
then allow you to use another technique
carbon dioxide or a physical method and
of course when you're killing animals
you don't necessarily have to deliver
these anesthetics Peyer vaporizer and
that may allow you to deliver much
higher concentrations which could be
lethal so going back to carbon dioxide
this is by far the most commonly used
way to kill rodents in labs as well as
it's used commonly in a number of other
species they simply involves the animal
breathing carbon dioxide in the chamber
until it loses consciousness and
eventually dies and it's popular because
it's simple and safe it does what it's
supposed to do it's cheap it doesn't
contaminate tissues which means you can
either do something of those tissues or
the carcasses of animals can be used for
food for other animals which is a
significant consideration in some cases
and some people find this much less
distressing than some of those other
methods we've talked about but concerns
about the welfare of this agent have
dogged it for years decades this paper
here is 20 years old now raising
concerns about whether it causes pain
and distress so I'll try and tackle
those two questions whether or not
carbon dioxide causes pain whether or
not it causes animals distressed by some
mechanism other than pain and throw in a
third question which is simply is there
something else that we could use now in
terms of an inhaled agent which would
allow us to comfortably replace carbon
dioxide if we have these concerns so the
pain issue is a pretty easy one to deal
with carbon dioxide reacts with water to
form carbonic acid that will happen
anywhere where there's water present
including on moist tissues in the bodies
of animals which were exposed to co2 so
the nasal passages the corneal
epithelium the respiratory tract and so
on
and that liberates protons which can
activate nociceptive neurons
acids causes stinging sensation we know
that and circumstantially there's
evidence to make us think that it's
pretty likely that exposing rome's to
high concentration of co2 would cause
pain first of all it hurts humans if you
breathe 50 percent co2 it will start to
hurt and the higher the concentration of
co2 that you breathe the more painful it
becomes and people use words like
excruciating to describe breathing a
hundred percent co2
there's nothing particularly different
about rodents in terms of the neural
mechanisms they would have for sensing
co2 as painful and indeed if you take in
a nice-sized rat and record from a
nociceptive pain sensing in other words
neuron in its nasal epithelium for
instance they do what
humans describe they start to respond to
co2 in about 50% and they show a linear
increase in their response in the number
of action potentials they fire as the
concentration of co2 increases that's a
lot of evidence to worry about putting
rodents in high concentrations of co2
that doesn't mean that every time
someone kills a rat or a mouse with
carbon dioxide they cause it pain
because there are different ways to use
co2 and most of you will know that one
approach to using co2 is to drop animals
into a chamber that's full of a hundred
percent co2 which is pretty much
guaranteed to cause the animal pain
albeit it will die quite quickly another
approach is to use what's called the
gradually rising or gradual fill method
whereby the animal goes into a chamber
which is empty typically and it's
gradually filled with co2 at something
like twenty percent of its volume per
minute typically somewhere between 10
and 30 and this is recommended and
mandated by all sorts of sets of
guidelines and legislation around the
world and for a good reason if you use
slow fill you take advantage of the fact
that carbon dioxide is a general
anaesthetic and it turns out that you
need 30 something percent or so of co2
to get a rat or a mouse unconscious
that's the MAC value essentially for co2
and so if you use one of these rising
fill gradual fill paradigms your rattle
Mouse will likely become unconscious
around about hi 30 percent of co2 or so
after a couple of minutes
two and a half minutes maybe and so what
what this means is that the animals
going to be unconscious before it's
exposed to those fifty percent plus
concentrations of co2 that we expect
might cause pain so to go back to my
fill curve again I've marked so this is
concentration of co2 on the vertical
axis versus time on the horizontal axis
and what you can see is that I've marked
a grey area which is where a typical rat
wouldn't
consciousness in a 20% per minute
filling chamber of co2 and it takes
another minute and a half two minutes to
get to that danger zone in red or pink
depending on how your screen looks which
is where potentially the animal could
suffer pain if we think the threshold is
about 50% so we can avoid causing these
animals pain so so far so good but
should we worry about using gradual fill
co2 and I'm going to argue that yes we
should
although we don't cause animals pain
there's significant evidence that
there's a danger of these animals
suffering stress or distress down here
in the left hand corner of this graph
which is the area before the animal can
become unconscious the first minute and
a half two minutes when it's exposed to
low concentrations of co2 because pretty
much every attempt to measure whether
these animals show aversion to co2 at
that kind of concentration finds that
they do and I'm going to show you some
of that evidence now and I think by far
the most compelling certainly the most
visually compelling of this evidence
comes from Dan where his lab at the
University of British Columbia where
they've developed this approach
avoidance paradigm so what they got here
in this diagram is two rat cages linked
by a achoo and a rat who's been taught
that he can go down is that lower box to
get a food reward that he's really quite
keen on retrieving in this case it's a
pile of honey nut cheerios and then what
you can do is ask what happens to that
rats behavior if I start pumping carbon
dioxide into that for their chamber and
what I'm going to do now hopefully if we
can cure it up is show you a video which
demonstrates exactly what this rat will
do so if we could have video one now
please so the rat is given a signal and
enters the chamber to retrieve his food
or world at which point the chamber
begins filling with carbon dioxide and
for a while this rat tolerates the
presence of carbon dioxide in order to
to get the delicious food award but in
well under a minute just over 30 seconds
or so in fact this rat detects the
presence of co2 and decides to exit the
chamber leaving behind some of the food
which would not probably happen if there
was only air in the chamber
right so hopefully you saw and heard
that video showing showing that rap
showing what I think is quite obvious
signs of aversion to carbon dioxide when
it was pumped into that chamber and what
he's done is leave behind his food award
which is something he would never do if
he just pumped air into that chamber so
a clear demonstration of behavioural
aversion and in another study the same
group have used fixed concentrations of
co2 to examine the threshold where it
starts to become a problem for these
animals and hopefully what you can see
is that when the carbon dioxide
concentration exceeds about ten percent
these animals start to sacrifice their
food reward to avoid spending time in
the presence of co2 by the time you hit
twenty percent co2 you've got no animals
exposing themselves to it in return for
a food award so I think that's
reasonably convincing signs of aversion
there it's worth at this point thinking
about the alternatives to co2 and the
same group reviews that's exact same
paradigm to look at what rats do when
they're exposed to argon all the
volatile anesthetic isoflurane in those
in that chamber and to cut a long story
short what they find is that argon is
substantially more aversive to these
animals than carbon dioxide and
isoflurane quite significantly less of
us if some animals spend a lot longer
eating their Cheerios in the presence of
isoflurane
and it's also worth saying that whenever
this group has examined mice the results
are very similar to those of rats we
shouldn't assume that mice are small
rats but in this case they are as averse
to carbon dioxide it would appear as as
rats
so does that prove the case a standard
fluffy welfarist like me would say that
if an animal avoid something it
demonstrates signs of aversion to that
stimulus and that tends to suggest that
it induces a negative affective state in
the animal it makes it feel bad in some
way that it wants
avoid and the extrapolation from that
would be that if I didn't give the
animal a tunnel to run up a way of
escaping the likely result would be
distress because the stimulus is both
inescapable and the animal lacks a
mechanism to adapt to it now you can
raise some objections to that there are
some objections sort of in principle
which are what if carbon dioxide changed
your motivational state or change the
deliciousness of honey nut cheerios
either way you maybe don't care about
being in that lower chamber anymore
because you don't have the motivation to
get the reward it also been suggested
once or twice to me that the nematode
worm C elegans which boasts a total of
302 neurons and probably isn't the most
sentient thing you've ever met can also
effectively do a similar task just by
traveling down a chemotactic gradient
there are also objections to whether or
not there are signs of a version based
on studies which simply look at the
behavior of animals which can't escape
co2 and find little overt behavioral
signs of what they suspect would be
distressing these animals and similarly
some studies fail to find physiological
markers of distress after the animals
have had these experiences so one study
which we did fairly recently in my
previous lab which we haven't published
yet is this conditioned place of Russian
study which attempted to examine a
version in a slightly different light by
asking the animals whether not just
whether they reverse to these substances
but whether they could remember that the
version and learn to avoid the place
where it occurred and this is really
just flipping the place preference
paradigm on its head which is typically
used to demonstrate the abuse potential
of highly rewarding drugs like heroin
and cocaine rats and mice can learn to
prefer a place where they've been
administered those drugs and it tells
you that they're rewarding similarly
they can learn to avoid places where bad
things happen so the basic approach
experiment was to expose a rat to a test
substance like carbon dioxide in this
chamber on the left and then on
alternate sessions expose him to air in
a chamber which is physically identical
it just has some stripes on the wall and
a different texture on the floor so he
can tell the two apart you do this a few
times to give him a chance to learn the
difference and then you open up a tunnel
between the two and give the animal of
free choice about where it wants to
spend its time at this point there's
only air in these two boxes and the
hypothesis would be if carbon dioxide is
bad news then the animal is going to
choose to spend time in the place where
it hasn't been exposed to co2 and to cut
a long story short those sorry ones like
before that the advantages of that
twofold I think first of all it relies
on memory so this animal can only make
decisions about where it spends its time
based on its memory of what happened in
those places when that tunnels opened up
there's nothing in there to confound its
decision based on changes in taste or
anything it can't travel down a
chemotactic gradient it simply has to
use its memory for this emotional
experience when it was exposed and the
other bonus for this kind of study is
that when you train these animals
they're confined in the inner chamber
and exposed to a rising concentration of
co2 it's inescapable it's exactly what
happens to animals when they're killed
with this stuff except that we rescue
them after 90 seconds or so just about
when they'd be on the cusp of losing
consciousness and so I'll cut to the
chase and show you the results and
basically the outcome of this study was
that in all the substances we tested we
found a strong conditioned place
aversion so we again similar to that
previous study looked at argon carbon
dioxide and isoflurane
and those dark blue bars represent the
animals initial preference for one side
or the other of that apparatus and it's
basically 50% give or take so they don't
care which side they spent time on
they're happy to move between the two
sides after they've been trained
conditioned by exposure to these
substances they demonstrate an aversion
for the side where they've been exposed
to them they spend less time on those
sides so that's a demonstration that
they can remember what happened and
avoid those places and that memory is
actually reasonably persistent over a
significant period of time as well in
terms of the magnitude of that aversion
in other words what's worst well we
agree strongly with those previous
results that argon is by far the most
aversive of those substances in terms of
carbon dioxide nicer fluorine in our
hands they actually came out for about
equal they're both aversive but they're
hard to distinguish in terms of the
magnitude of aversion and just just to
emphasize what I mean when I say
profoundly aversive talking about argon
I'm gonna flip back to some some more
video from Dan weari who's kindly shared
this one which is going to show you a
rat doing exactly that same task that
you told before in the first video but
this time going down into a chamber
that's full of argon so it's about 98%
argon in there so if we could run video
to now please
you
okay so hopefully you can see a pretty
dramatic difference with with argon that
these animals really are bred spent any
time in the presence of an atmosphere
that's effectively entirely argon its
profoundly aversive none of the animals
at any of their food reward and that
really corresponds very much to what we
found with place aversion so going back
to carbon dioxide we've demonstrated I
think quite convincingly that it is a
verse if the question is why is it
aversive or at least I think that's a
question that's worth asking because it
might help us understand what this
welfare problem is for these animals and
there are several candidates mechanisms
one area that's often raised although
the evidence is not particularly
overwhelming is that it may be an
adaptation to borrowing these are
animals who live in burrows and they
appear to be highly sensitive to co2
more sensitive than other species at
least rats and mice amongst the rodents
appear to be very sensitive to co2 and
that may be because they live in burrows
and we can tell this from a number of
studies there studies done in ivc's
which show that rodents will avoid
single-digit concentrations of co2 when
they build up in you know even seas and
in terms of mice we know that they're
exquisitely sensitive to co2 they can
detect concentrations way down there
atmospheric concentrations they can
actively avoid nor point two percent co2
and they appear to have a neural
mechanism for effectively detecting a
trial or faction they have neurons in
the nasal epithelium which connected
directly to the olfactory bulb and which
are sensitive to carbon dioxide which is
something that certainly humans lack we
would be oblivious to these kind of
concentrations and this might be some
adaptation to detecting co2 so having
told you that we probably shouldn't be
anthropomorphic about the way rats and
mice deal with co2 because they've got
different mechanisms they may also share
some of our responses to excess carbon
dioxide and one of those might be
dyspnea the sensation of air hunger or
the uncomfortable
breathes and breathing about 7% co2 will
cause dyspnea in humans it's a similar
sensation to having an asthma attack and
it's very unpleasant and there's reason
to suspect this might happen in rodents
and I apologize I missed the reference
off but there's a really good review by
nyow Beausoleil and colleagues in the
new zealand vet journal which is really
worth reading raising the question of
whether we cause dyspnea in animals we
exposed to co2 so that's one area of
concern I think one that is even better
evidence for is that carbon dioxide
induces fear in both people and animals
and breathing about 20% co2 will induce
a panic attack in vulnerable humans
people who are vulnerable to panic
attacks in one or two breaths
similarly brief exposure to 20% co2 in
rodents can be shown to activate the
panic and defence areas of the brain
which have brain involved in the
fight-or-flight reflex the hypothalamic
pituitary axis and so on which tends to
correlate what humans experience and
even more interestingly I think if you
get humans to breathe seven and a half
percent carbon dioxide so not very much
co2 in a normal atmosphere so you add
back in enough oxygen that they're
breathing 21% co2 just like they would
be in normal atmospheric air they feel
anxious and they use all these lists of
words that you can see a higher
frequency in the right-hand column to
describe how they feel when they're
breathing co2 and I think that third one
down is completely fascinating feel like
leaving they want to get out of the
place where they're breathing this stuff
and that sounds remarkably like what
those rats and going down into that
chamber to get their Cheerios decide
that they want to do and I think this
really argues quite strongly that what
we do when we expose rodents to carbon
dioxide even in low concentrations is we
induce some form of anxiety and if that
isn't enough to convince you I'm going
to resort to some serious molecular
biology
to try and underpin this point this is a
really interesting study from Zeeman and
colleagues from a few years ago now
which in my son picked both the receptor
mechanism and the anatomical substrate
for come up side induced fear in Mice
and mice display fear quite often by a
freezing behavior so it's an anti
predator mechanism that they all freeze
when they're afraid and mice will also
display freezing when they're breathing
concentrations of co2 around about ten
percent so in this left hand graph if
you just look at the open unfilled bars
you'll see that at ten percent co2 these
mice suddenly start displaying a lot of
freezing behaviour so we've got a sort
of potential anxiety response in these
mice and really fascinatingly what this
group did was knock out an ion channel
called the assic 1a acid sensing ion
channel and these are the responses of
the mice on in the black bars in this
left-hand graph and you can see that the
freezing response is significantly
attenuated in the mice that have had
this gene knocked out so we now know
roughly what's responsible for at least
a large chunk of this response it's an
ion channel that's responsible for
sensing low pH in the brain which makes
sense because carbon dioxide induces low
pH it induces acidosis when you breathe
it even I think more convincingly than
that the same group went on and asked
which bit of the brain is the bit and
that might be responsible for this and
they looked unsurprisingly at the
amygdala a bit of the brain that's
involved in emotional responses
suspected to be involved in fear
responses and the way they tested this
was to inject bicarbonate into the
amygdala and bicarbonate will neutralize
the acidosis induced by
oxide and lo and behold that attenuates
the freezing response in these mice so
we've got the anatomical location and
the
the molecular mechanism for this so I
think putting all this together it
argues very strongly that even load
concentrations of co2 cause fear anxiety
so I may or may not have convinced you
that there's probably carbon dioxide
what we really want is a solution if we
believe there's a problem and one
commonly suggested solution is pre
anesthesia in other words using a
volatile anesthetic drug to get these
animals unconscious before they're
killed and the Canadian Council on
animal care has been right at the
forefront of advocating this change
they've said that carbon dioxide
shouldn't be used where there's a better
alternative and one of their suggested
alternatives is Anisa sizing the animal
with a inhalants volatile anesthetic so
is that the solution well I've already
told you that in those approach
avoidance studies isoflurane and
sevoflurane I think appear less aversive
than carbon dioxide but I also told you
that when I did place aversion studies
it was hard to distinguish the two they
appeared equally aversive and I think
there's some really interesting data
from the same lab from Dan weary and his
colleagues in Vancouver which sheds some
light on why we might have found those
differences amongst other things and
what they did was develop basically the
opposite version of their reward
motivated task where they used a version
motivated task and rats generally don't
like to hang out in brightly lit areas
where they're in danger of predation and
so on if you put them in a light dark
box like this one you can see they will
tend to give them the choice hang out in
the dark where they feel safe and so
they simply ask the question what if you
pump carbon dioxide into that dark area
are you going to force this animal to
take the risk and go out in the brightly
lit area to avoid the co2 or indeed
isoflurane and the results from that
study on first glimpse were entirely
consistent with all the previous data
it's from the same lab so you can ignore
the lnh conditions here they're just
different life levels just concentrate
on the co2 in green and the isoflurane
in the red what you're looking at is
dwelling time in the dark area you can
see that carbon dioxide pushes these
animals out into the light area so
they'll take the risk to go and be in
what they perceive to be a dangerous
place or an unpleasant place to avoid
co2 in the case of isoflurane they spend
a lot longer in the presence of the
substance and some of them even let
themselves become effectively in these
ties they start to become recumbent so
that all looks jolly good
in terms of using isoflurane as a better
alternative to co2
they also loaded something really
interesting if you look at those second
hatched bars that I've just put up those
are the responses of rats who were re
exposed to co2 they're exposed to second
time and that's not very surprising
there's no chains they're still averse
to carbon dioxide so they don't seem to
change their response on a second
exposure if you expose rats to
isoflurane a second time there's a
really pronounced change in their level
of aversion so they now have become just
about as averse to isoflurane as the
other rats are to co2 and I think what
that says is that these animals learn
something during their first exposure
which made them more averse to co2 at a
lighter flaring I'm sorry the second
time so we've probably got some kind of
learning mechanism going on and that
explains the difference between place
aversion experiments which involve
multiple exposures to train the animals
and tests where the animals might be
naive so I think place aversion
overestimates the response because it
relies on animals being exposed to these
drugs several times to learn the
aversion to the place so naive animals
it's likely to be lower and and perhaps
those approach avoidance experiments are
more indicative of the level of aversion
as long as these animals haven't met
these drugs before so they may well be a
bit
an alternative at least for animals that
have never seen these drugs before of
course quite a lot of lab rats and might
may have been exposed to isoflurane for
surgical procedures and that's a
question that really needs to be
addressed when we think about killing
one as does something that's well
outside the purview of this talk which
is the use of multiple anesthetics so at
this point I'm going to sort of sum up
my conclusions about the evidence and
then go on to think about what we might
do in the future so really I would say
most of the physical methods are not
going to cause an instant death there is
some concern they might call suffering
for short periods of time
there are also procedural concerns and
clearly a need for people to be very
well trained to use them Penta barbers
we've discussed may cause pain
there are ways that might get us around
that but there are also other issues
with handling and a long induction
carbon dioxide I think put bluntly
offers you a choice between a quick
painful death if you drop a rat into a
hundred percent co2 it will lose
consciousness in ten or fifteen seconds
but if those ten or fifteen seconds
they're not going to be pleasant or you
can use co2 in a slowly rising
concentration and cause a slow anxious
fearful death a version to co2 is I
think demonstrably significant from
those studies and others and it almost
certainly causes fear because we now
understand something about the mechanism
by which that might come about and that
aversion occurs at low levels where we
couldn't get the animal unconscious so
the animal is going to have to
experience that every time it's exposed
to carbon dioxide I've shown you that I
think from rats and mice argon is almost
certainly worse isoflurane may well be
an improvement a significant refinement
especially for naive animals but there
are some questions to think about for
animals who haven't who have been
exposed to this before
so going back to what we thought about a
start how are we gonna choose the least
harmful method and I think really what
I'm going to argue for is that we need
to think about these methods really hard
every time we decide to use animals we
need to think about how they're killed
lists of acceptable methods like we have
in the UK and lots of places have a fine
in terms of prohibiting the really
really awful ways of killing these
animals but just taking the box to say
I've chosen one of the list of
acceptable methods I'm not sure is the
ideal way and what we should probably be
doing is thinking hard about the current
evidence about these techniques and
factoring them into the harm benefit
analysis they're all potential harms and
therefore they should be in the heart
benefit analysis but we have a lot of
unknowns as well and that's what I
really like to advocate for is trying to
close some of the gaps in our knowledge
about these agents which would allow us
to make better decisions and do better
harm benefit analysis we know these
agents on welfare problems or at least I
think they are but how bad are they how
bad is being put in carbon dioxide
compared to post-surgical pain in a rat
or being a mouse who's too cold because
you haven't been given enough bedding
that would allow us to put these in
context and know how much we should
really be worrying about these issues
compared to other issues for these
animals on more specific nature I think
we need to think about understanding
more about the response to some of these
volatile anesthetics and even more
importantly than any of that at the end
of this I'd like to emphasize that what
I think we should really be doing is
looking for a better way to kill these
animals it's not futile to think that
there's a better way to kill these
animals which might be entirely humane
there are methods for stunning livestock
when they're slaughtered for meat
captive bolts tellers electrical
stunning of sheep and so on that appear
to render animals insensible almost
instantaneously allow them to be killed
in what many people would regard to be a
humane manner and experimentally we've
seen demonstrations that are gone
actually
although it looks horrible for rodents
might be quite a humane way of getting
pigs unconscious and we'll come to that
in a second when we queue up the very
last video and also we've seen recent
evidence that fish are less averse to
some novel agents than some of the
traditional anesthetics that used to
kill them and I'm now going to show you
why we need to consider species when we
look at different ways of killing these
animals by showing you very quickly the
response of a pig placed in an
experiment where he's exposed to argon
so this pig is doing his version of the
Cheerios experiment but this time from a
reward of apples in a chamber that's
effectively almost free of air contains
about 98% argon and as you can see shows
no detectable sign of aversion and in
fact lets himself become rendered almost
unconscious and just to prove that
there's no signs of assertion that pig
goes back for a second attempt
okay so hopefully what you saw there is
that pigs appear at least in an
experimental setup to be perfectly happy
to expose themselves to an atmosphere
that contains almost no air and I'd like
to thank Raj who shared that video and
did some really pioneering work looking
at this raccoon in Bristol and I think
that just really says there are methods
that we should think about that can be
humane for a certain species and why
can't we find them for rodents here's a
few random thoughts about what they what
they might be devices to mechanically
assist cervical dislocation to make sure
it's more reliable how about some
physical stunners for rodents in the
wild we have this good nature trap with
a little diagram there where a rat goes
and sticks his head up a baited tube and
get trips a little trigger and gets shot
in the head by a captive bolt the last
thing that that rat knows about is being
incredibly pleased that he's found some
delicious food that seems probably like
a better way to go than some of the
things we've talked about low
atmospheric pressures stunning has been
suggested for birds and pigs it might
work for rodents someone should
certainly check it maybe that rodents
care more about hypoxia than other
animals but it's worth looking maybe we
can find novel chemical agents in their
injectable agents read enta science who
knows rats have been killed in labs and
others livestock species have been
experimentally killed using focused
microwave irradiation it's worth looking
to see if that's humane and who knows
there's got to be something out there
somewhere just the very last slide
because it always comes up people say
I'm still using co2 or I'm using ice
flaring what can we do in the meantime
to refine it well one thing that comes
up quite often is a little bit of
evidence but not much to suggest it's an
improvement is to kill animals in their
home cage take all the procedural stress
out of the equation by not taking them
out handling them placing them in an
unfilial unfamiliar environment there
are all sorts of other refinements like
study we did showing that adding nitrous
oxide can get animals unconscious faster
when you're using carbon dioxide there
is clearly an optimal fill rate as well
which hasn't been found yet it might be
that 20% isn't the ideal fill rate then
you can get animals unconscious faster
without causing pain I think all of
those are only refinements though and
they're still going to be issues but
it's worth being aware and trying to
refine your current practice until we
can replace these agents I just at the
end conclude very quickly by saying I
think it's hard to understand when
they're animals death so humane or not
but we've made huge progress there's
some amazing studies there and lots of
others that I haven't had time to talk
about we need to put this into our
benefit analysis because all of them are
a welfare problem and we need to find a
better way of doing it at the very end
I'll thank the nc3 hours who supported
the research in my lab alongside you for
who supported me even before they gave
me a job and Charles River who also
supported some of the research and some
of my colleagues and at the end I will
leave up this slide just with some links
to other sources of information if
that's of any use to anyone and take
some questions let Steve take out the
hard ones for me well thank you for that
really informative presentation before
we get started on the question/answer
session I'd like to remind you the
audience on how you can submit questions
you can submit questions by typing in
the Q&A box which could be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left on the presentation window
we'll try and answer as many questions
as we can in 10 minutes or so that we've
got available so our first question if
we're going through so Deb Hickman at
Indiana University asks the induction of
anesthesia is distressing so with the
animals not have suffered during
induction of anesthesia prior to a
chemical overdose or physical methods
well that's a good question I don't
think we understand what the these
animals are using to learn that exposure
to isoflurane is distressing so
something bad happened that first time
that they're exposed but bear in mind
that these animals also had to recover
they weren't they were exposed they went
into that chamber they're exposed to
isoflurane they then had to go through
the recovery process so it's unclear
whether it's the induction or the
recovery or the ongoing exposure when
they're walking around in that chamber
which is the problem so I think we're
not certain yet is the answer they don't
display immediate signs of trying to
avoid it on the first 30 seconds or so
of induction so it might be more humane
but I agree that there are some concerns
and certainly we need more experiments
and I suspect isoflurane isn't perfect
at the very least Deb Hickman's
also asked another question too from
Indiana University please comment on EG
and consciousness as compared to
reflexive response to pain the
decapitation yeah a good point neither
of them are particularly brilliant
measures of consciousness because we can
clearly record that EEG in an
unconscious animal which is anesthetized
so we can't be certain that it would
have been conscious and you can have
reflex responses when you're in a size 2
so unfortunately we don't have a neural
signature of consciousness which will
allow us to unequivocally diagnose
whether a decapitated rat is still
conscious and perceiving what's going on
let alone whether it's in pain and that
is a real problem
I think so I've simply raised those
ongoing EEG zazz something to worry
about the absence of an EEG would be
much more reassuring that the animal was
unconscious or dead and question from
Mary Wieck the Fred Hutchinson Cancer
Research Center please clarify
euthanasia by concussion is another
method employed following them
absolutely sorry I should have said that
I think typically people would do some
local dislocation
capitation something like that yeah
absolutely I should have said that if I
didn't Lynn never honor at AstraZeneca
says Ken pentobarb be administered via
the rat tail vein instead of IP for a
quickie death I would have thought so
I've certainly done that in a nice-sized
animal so you already had a tailbone
line in place I think the worry is just
that lots of people don't have the skill
to get a tailbone line in an animal
particularly one who's not particularly
compliant with being handled dead
Hickman again from Indiana University a
very low flow at approximately 20% is
what you're focusing on
aside from fully charged chambers what
is your opinion on gradual filled
chambers 40 to 60% there's some
literature such as that by damn weary
that says 50% maybe better for mice yeah
I agree I think I touched on that at the
end that we certainly can look for the
optimal flow rate that'll get these
animals unconscious as quickly as
possible without touching on the areas
where they might be in pain and 20% was
a somewhat arbitrary guess on what might
be a good fill rate I just still think
it will take a significant amount of
time to get those animals unconscious
and they're not going to avoid feeling
anxiety during that but I agree and I
encourage attempts to find the optimal
fill rate a question from AG net from
the Institute of industrial organic
chemistry can co2 be used in tox
illogical studies when in effect the
grosser histopathology histopathology
examinations it may well do it certainly
causes signs of bleeding in the lungs
sometimes and so on I'm not a toxicology
story history pathologist so I will
defer to their expertise but it
certainly could be a confound in some
studies and you may well mean Jodie
gastrich from Mercy Health says have the
beam evaluations of additives to co2 to
counteract the negative sensations and
perceptions so there's a study by
Valentine and colleagues looking at the
sort of standard anesthetic pre-meds and
really in their hands they didn't find
any great improvement and of course
generally what you're talking about that
is in
acting animal with a drug and handling
it and stressing it out by doing that
before you kill it with this other
stress inducing agent so that may not be
the way around it
the other thing that's often taught
about of course is what if I add oxygen
to keep the animal normal optic and just
kill it
with the co2 and I think Dan weary and
colleagues found that that really didn't
help that it does seem to be the co2 per
se rather than the hypoxia that's the
issue argue zakah Drecker from the
experimental center research central
Delp and pharmaceutical company says do
you have any data regarding the use of
sever fluorine compared to Isis so again
I'm going to point to down when his
colleagues at UBC he did look at C
though I think generally the responses
are quite similar and that does include
development of a stronger version when
you've met it more than once
Tim called from the animal and plant
health agency in Weybridge the UK says
regarding the immersion test I can
understand the emotion to see a 2 but
could the aversion to isoflurane not be
caused by the smell which may not
necessarily be stressful
what are you better to have a controlled
experiment where the controls are
rodents that are exposed to air with a
strange but not harmful smell I think
some of these studies do include certain
some the approach avoidance studies have
used things like menthol and I don't
think it's the smell per se but I
strongly suspect that what they're doing
is learning that the smell is is the
indicator that something is unpleasant
is going to happen so in other words we
could have kind of Pavlovian response to
the smell and that would what what would
make ice very easy to learn about that
the smell will come on long before the
effects that we suspect might be what's
making these animals averse to it which
might I suspect be more likely to be
nausea given the human response to some
of these drugs Lilian Gomez says
according to the bay study mentioned
previously 7.5 percent of carbon dioxide
is oxygenated in humans is that an
average of a study with a specific group
considering divers and the treatment of
panic and converted syndrome at the
emergency room using a bag
given to the patient breathing instead
of BZ dancin SS be ice so I think as I
remember and it's a while ago that study
is looking at people who are naive it is
an average and you're just looking at
their percentage changes the regulation
of all of those reports self reports of
how they feel whilst breathing seven and
a half percent co2 from a bag and man
it's over a relatively prolonged as in
minutes exposure so it's not the sort of
single breath stuff that causes a panic
attack at 20%
so Damien O'Donoghue from prospect
solution says I don't mind being drunk
as much as I hate the subsequent
hangover so in the conditioned place
preference studies how much the animals
displeasure is derived from the
explosion to the test cats and how much
is due to a post exposure yeah I think
we just just basically covered that and
I also took out the slide of the mouse
holding a bottle a tiny little bottle of
vodka because that was that was one of
my hypotheses - that it may well be that
recovering from some of that anesthesia
that's the problem
and that really needs unpicking Anna
Valentin from IBM C says do you know if
there is any discussion to review the
European directive regarding euthanasia
taking out argon and nitrogen as agents
to be used in rodents I'm not party to
the discussions in Europe the UK didn't
transcribe that part they left out the
inert gases unfortunately we also took
them out for the farm species I think
and it clearly strongly argues for a
sort of species specific consideration
of that inclusion because it's
justifiably included for some other
species looking at the time I think
we've only got time for one last
question I'm afraid there's lots of come
in so we've just had to sort of pick
through them final question is from
Marcel parent gentle it's an excellent
discussion thank you for the powerful
insights so in light of the presented
evidence on the use of co2 for
euthanasia of rodents what are your
thoughts on the APA made guidelines of a
10 to 3 percent air displacement rate
someone was bound to ask me that
I'm not sure we got the evidence to say
that that's not the best way to use co2
at the moment but I would keep in mind
as Deb raised earlier the flow rate a
higher flow rate might be better and
it's almost a philosophical judgment as
to whether you prefer pre-fill and a
quick painful death to a slow anxious
one which I hadn't solved in my own mind
and to be honest I would prefer to not
have to think about it by finding a
better way to use co2 but I think there
may be some more studies around which
will clarify what might be the best of a
bad bunch of flow rates as it were okay
well I'd like to thank dr. Hugh College
once again for his excellent
presentation before we finish any final
comments um thanks a lot for listening
there's my email address there if you
want to send more questions I think you
can send questions by lab routes as well
and I'm more than happy to answer more
questions or to provide more info but
thank you very much for virtually
listening thank you and just to finish
them today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing to the next six
months until July 2016 and you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay so we invite you to forward
this announcement to your colleagues you
may miss today's live event thank you
very much for watching thank you